okay yeah we're gonna see situations
where our nearest neighbor averaging
doesn't work so well and we're going to
have to find ways to deal with that
nearest neighbor averaging which is the
one we just saw can be pretty good for
small P small numbers of variables here
we had just one variable
but small maybe P less than equal to
four and largest n right we're not large
n so that we have enough points in each
neighbor to average to give us our
estimate
now this is just one version of a whole
class of techniques called smoothers and
and we're going to discuss later on in
this course much cleverer ways of doing
this kind of averages such as kernel and
spline smoothing
now there's a problem though nearest
neighbor methods can be really lousy
when p is large and the reason has got
the name the curse of dimensionality
what it boils down to is that nearest
neighbors tend to be far away in high
dimensions
so
and that creates a problem
we need to get a reasonable fraction of
the N values of y i to average to bring
the variance down so we need to average
a number of points in each neighborhood
so that the estimate has has got a nice
reasonably small variance
and let's suppose we want 10 of the data
points to be in each interval
the problem is a 10 neighborhood in high
Dimensions need no longer be local so we
lose the spirit of estimating the
conditional expectation by local
averaging
so let's look at a little example of
that
in the left panel
we've got values of two variables X1 and
X2 and they actually uniformly
distributed in this little cube with bat
with edges minus one to plus one minus
one to plus one
and we form two 10 neighborhoods in this
case
the first neighborhood is just you
involving the variable X1 ignoring X2
and so that's indicated by the vertical
dotted lines
our Target point is at zero
and so we spread out a neighborhood to
the left and right until we capture ten
percent of the data points with respect
to to the variable X1 and the dotted
line indicates the width of the
neighborhood
alternatively if we want to find a
neighborhood in two Dimensions we spread
out a circle centered at the Target
point which is the Red Dot there until
we've captured ten percent of the points
now notice the radius of the circle in
two Dimensions is much bigger than the
radius of the the circle in one
Dimensions which is just the width
between these these two dotted lines
and so to capture ten percent of the
points in two Dimensions we have to go
out further and and less and so we less
local than we are in one dimension
and so we can take this example further
and on the right hand plot I've shown
you how far you have to go out in one
two three five and ten dimensions
in in 10 Dimensions these are different
versions of this problem as we go as the
dimensions get higher in order to
capture
a certain fraction of the volume
okay and so take for example uh 10 or
0.1 fraction of the volume
so for p equals 1 if the data is uniform
you roughly go at 10 percent of of the
the the distance right
in two Dimensions we saw you went more
look what happens in in five dimensions
in five Dimensions you have to go out
about 0.9 on each coordinate axis to get
10 of the data that's just about the
whole radius of the sphere
and in 10 Dimensions you actually have
to go break out of the sphere in order
to get points in the corner to capture
the ten percent
so the the bottom line here is it's
really hard to find near neighborhoods
in high dimensions and stay local
if this problem didn't exist we would
use near-nabis near neighbor averaging
as the sole basis for doing estimation
so how do we deal with this well we
introduce structure to our models and so
the simplest structural model is a
linear model and so here we have an
example of a linear model we've got P
features
it's just got P plus one parameters and
it says the the function of X we can
approximate by a linear function so
there's a coefficient on each of the x's
and an intercept so that's one of the
simplest structural models
um we can estimate the parameters of the
model by fitting the model to training
data and we'll be talking more about how
you do that
and when we use such a structural model
and of course this structural model is
going to avoid the cursive
dimensionality because it's not relying
on any local properties
um and nearest neighbor averaging let's
just fit in a quite a rigid model to all
the data
now
a linear model is almost never correct
but it often serves as a good
approximation an interpretable
approximation to the unknown true
function f of x
so
here's our same little example data set
and we can see in the in the top plot a
linear model gives a reasonable fit to
the data not perfect
in the bottom plot we've augmented our
linear model and we've included a
quadratic term so we put in our X and we
put in an x squared as well
and we see that fits the data much
better
it's also a linear model but it's linear
in in some transformed values of x
and notice now we've put hats on each of
the parameters because suggesting
they've been estimated in this case from
these uh from these training data these
little hats indicate that they've been
estimated from the training data
okay so those are two parametric models
structured models that uh that seem to
do a good job in this case
you dimensional example again seniority
years of education and income
and this is simulated data and so the
blue surface is actually showing you the
true function from which the data was
simulated with errors we can see the
errors aren't big
each of those data points comes from a
particular pair of years of education
and seniority with some error and the
little little line segments in the in
the data point show you the error okay
so we can write that as income as a
function of education and seniority plus
some error all right so this this is the
truth we actually know this in this case
and here's a linear regression model fit
to those simulation data
so you know it's an approximation it
captures the important elements of the
relationship but doesn't doesn't capture
everything okay it's got three
parameters
the more flexible regression model
we've actually fit this using a
technique called thin plate splines and
that's a nice smooth version of of a
two-dimensional smoother it's different
from nearest neighbor averaging and it's
got some nicer properties
and you can see this does a pretty good
job if we go back to the generating data
and the generating surface
this thin plate spline actually captures
more of the essence of what's going on
there
and for thin space planes we're going to
talk about them later in chapter seven
there's a there's a tuning parameter
that controls how smooth the surfaces
here's an example of a thin plate spline
where we basically tune the parameter
all the way down to zero and this
surface actually goes through every
single data point
in this case that's overfitting the data
we expect to have some errors because
the true function
generate data points with errors so this
is known as overfitting we overfit in
the training data
so this is an example where we've got a
family of functions and we've got a way
of controlling the complexity
so there's some trade-offs when when
building models
one trade-off is prediction accuracy
versus interpretability so linear models
are easy to interpret we just got a few
parameters thin plate splines are not
they they give you a whole surface back
and if you get given a surface back in
in 10 Dimensions it's it's hard to
understand what it's what it's actually
telling you
we can have a good fit versus versus
over fit or underfit so in this previous
example the middle one was a good fit
the linear was slightly under fit and
the and the the last one was overfit so
how do we know when the fit is just
right
we need to be able to select amongst
those
parsimony versus Black Box
parsimony means having a model that's
simpler and can be
um
that can be transmitted with a
small number of parameters and explain
in a simple fashion and involve maybe a
subset of the predictors
um
and you know and so those models if they
do as well as say a black box predictor
like the thin plate spline or somewhat
of a black box predictor we'd prefer the
simpler model
it's a little uh
schematic which shows a variety of the
methods that we're going to be
discussing in this course
and they ordered by interpretability and
flexibility
and at the top there are two versions of
of linear regression
subset selection and lassu which we'll
talk about that actually even think the
linear regression models too complex and
try and reduce it by throwing out some
of the variables
linear models and least squares
slightly more flexible
but you lose some interpretability
because now all the variables are thrown
in
then we have generalized additive models
we allow which allow for transformations
in an automatic way of each of the
variables and then at the High
flexibility low interpretability and our
bargain boosting and support Vector
machines we will discuss all these
techniques but but later on in the
course
okay so we covered linear regression and
we covered nearest neighbor averaging
and we talked about ways places where
those where that's not going to work and
so we've
briefly introduced a number of other
different methods and they're all listed
on the screen
different methods that we can use to
solve the problem when the dimensions
high and and and when linearity doesn't
work but we have to choose amongst these
methods and so we need to develop ways
of of making those choices and that's
what we're going to cover in the next
segment